دعوات لتظاهرات جديده تعلو في ايران
والمعلمون يساندون العمال في احتجاجاتهم
لرفع اجورهم ومستحقاتهم ادعوات هذه تتزامن
مع تسجيل العمله المحليه الايرانيه مزيدا
من الانخفاض في قيمتها الشرائيه وتفاقم
الغلاء في ايران فيما اعلن المجلس
التنسيقي للمنظمات النقابيه للمعلمين في
البلاد دعمه لدعوه المتقاعدين اقامه
تجمعات احتجاجيه غدا وكانت عده مدن شهدت
احتجاجات عماليه ونقابيه مندده بتدهور
الوضع الاقتصادي وسط تاخر الرواتب
والزيادات التي وعدوا بها منذ اشهر هذا
ونظم متقاعدون شركه اطفاء للاتصالات مسيره
احتجاجيه للمطالبه بتطبيق لائحه الرعايه
الاجتماعيه لعام 2000 واحتجاجا على
مشاكلهم المعيشيه من خلال ترديد شعارات
مناوئه للحكومه